hey guys it's Justine and today we're
checking out the brand new a GoPro Hero
7 black if you guys know I have sort of
like this love-hate relationship with
GoPro the GoPro karma obviously was by
far the worst thing that I've ever
experienced in my entire life don't
patch it it might come along but this
GoPro and even the previous version the
hero 6 you guys know I'm such a huge fan
of small portable cameras all of the
reviews that I've seen and everyone that
has been talking about this camera has
said that they've absolutely been in
love with it and this is the camera the
GoPro has needed to make for some time
one of the huge highlights and something
that I did notice and some test footage
that I've seen is the audio is much
better that is one thing that I've just
been harping on GoPro please give us
better audio granted these are action
cameras so a lot of times the stuff that
this is made for there's usually not
audio involved but why not make a camera
that can do both great audio great
picture quality small compact issues 12
megapixel photos 4k 60 you can shoot 240
frames a second at 1080p one of the
things that I like about the most recent
GoPros and you don't have to put an
external housing on it this is
waterproof up to 10 meters voice
activated touch controls 8 X slo-mo GPS
HDR I just stab myself with my knife I
can't wait to test this out gimbal like
hyper smooth I think it's time to open
this look at that tab I got out all of
my recent GoPro things right here so
these are the past two versions ago
grows the hero 6 and the hero 5 the hero
6 had incredible image stabilization not
necessarily when you were kind of moving
around from side to side but going
forward and straight and just walking it
was great
so here it is just take out all the
stuff here some paperwork stickers comes
with of course these extra sticky mounts
got your USB see the battery which I'm
hoping this is the same battery as the
previous version so the battery looks a
little bit different like it has more of
like a textured finish to it so this is
the new battery this is the old battery
it looks the same I love these dual
battery chargers what's kind of cool is
this is actually called the hero black
and the color is black whereas these
previous versions were kind of like a
more tinted little grey color
so in embarrassin - this is
sony RX hero and i love this camera the
audio was great it has a large sensor so
it brings in a lot of light when I used
to vlog a lot more I used to use this
all the time so this is still such an
incredible high quality camera you can
do audio in you can also do external 4k
recording and that was probably one of
the only things that I had kind of a
gripe about is it didn't record 4k but
you can do 4k external recording if you
chose to do so so here's the Sony
compared to this little GoPro about the
same size like the unboxing now it's
time to test this out the rest of this
video is going to be pretty much
completely shot on this GoPro
the GoPro that's not safe
what did you get your GoPro oh my god
drifting that was centimeters away from
hitting Mac yes
[Music]
the bar I've been so impressed with the
tables they
you guys can see in our bike ride the
stabilization on the 6 and the 7 it is
almost I mean you can compare it but
there really isn't it compares the 7
wins by a long shot now let's check out
the 120 frames a second while we ride on
the bike
[Music]
30 frames a second
4k 30 40 30
[Music]
there's also a new portrait mode so when
you rotate the GoPro you can shoot
vertical videos and photos as you can
see this is not recording in vertical
the little record button is at the top
new shoes who dis it looks so cool I'm
glad that they added this feature and
this is really great for Instagram okay
vertical video here it is
but you guys think probably looks
exactly the same but it was horizontal
it's just now vertical it's magic also
at the beginning of this video you guys
may have noticed I did sort of like this
little time-lapse thing it's called a
time warp and I thought that I was
recording normal video until I went and
looked at it and I did it it was a time
lapse it still looks really cool but it
wasn't what I had intended on filming
since I'm in New York I'm gonna try out
that time warp one more time walking
back to my hotel
[Music]
[Applause]